I'm gonna dive into this but before I do
I just kind of want to give you a little
bit of context about what we've built
and this so kind of we built our own
database as an alternative to kind of
spark or storm I'm not exactly sure what
you've used but that's kind of the
context for this we wanted a simple
solution in order to effectively
efficiently cheaply store our data and
that's what we built as a bit of an
introduction to myself my name is Josh I
originally started out working in tech
building startups in South Africa worked
on a billing product worked on a website
hosting company probably more
interestingly i guess i walked worked on
the core infrastructure team at
instagram help them build out a
continuous deployment system and help
them are great from awss data center to
Facebook's data center which was a bit
of an engineering challenge right now
I'm the CTO at smite which is a trust
and safety platform for the Internet
essentially it's an anti-spam system web
and anti-fraud website send us
everything that's going on we tried enta
fire bad actors figure out as much as we
can out of the little information we
have combining counting machine learning
and any kind of data streams we can get
this talk is really about the counting
that we do something like how much
activity is on a given IP address which
you can imagine is fairly important for
spam like how many requests have that
has that IP address seen in the last
hour we also look at ipv6 which has
about that hundreds of billions more
addresses which becomes very very
challenging to store we'd look at black
specific events so how many synapse has
come from the single IP address in the
last hour how many sign ups has come
from the combination of the RP address
and kind of hotmail com or gmail com and
then also interestingly we do this thing
called the sim hash which converts a
blob of text into a very concise summary
of it I guess and then how many actors
have used similar text
in the last hour if you start seeing a
lot of the same texts it probably means
it's fairly spammy this talks about this
counter early which is how many
different kind of unique things has a
single person used so in this case it's
how many different unique billing zip
codes has an actor used if that numbers
above three or four that can be pretty
bad for a payments website usually
people only have their home and maybe
work address that they use for the stop
then the standard kind of algorithm
everyone uses for this thing is called a
hyper log log not going to type into all
the technical details of that but
essentially it gives you kind of an
efficient estimate counter value so you
throw a whole lot of values in and it
will tell you I saw around 50 more
importantly what we really wanted was
the sliding hyper log log which is
essentially exactly the same thing but
you can ask it for how many different
values of the last hour last day of last
week and it stores that weight more
efficiently than storing every single
value of course what was interesting
with this is when we figured out this is
what we wanted and we googled it we got
very very little results since these
things fairly new this top one was
actually September 2015 so that after we
built the system and the bottom two are
both the white paper explaining this
algorithm so essentially we land up with
the only available open source solution
which was this really kind of basic
proof-of-concept written in Python but
it worked and kind of we were just
getting started with this thing so let's
take what we can build it during takeoff
and like figure out how to get this
really basic part and implementation
running as one of our production
databases just a very quick overview of
what a database like what's important
for a database this is kind of from the
engineering side but they're pretty
basic concepts as shotted kind of refers
to whether you can divide your database
up into lots of kind of shards that
makes it wait if you can't chart it then
that means you need one giant machine
then lots of small machines lots of
small machines is way cheaper accuracy
is kind of yeah needed to actually give
you the correct answers atomic refers to
whether you can make updates in a
repeatable way and whether any errors
will land you up with bad data which you
never want cheap durable is whether you
lose your data not replicated whether
you can have copies of it so essentially
you want two different ones runnin with
the same data at any point so you can
kind of access both and fault-tolerant
is can you store access that when one of
those replicas goes down I guess so
basically getting up and running as
quick as we can I'll just run through
our initial solution which is using this
product called Redis which is very
expensive to run it stores everything in
the computer's memory but they give you
these very very easily use fast
in-memory data structures and they
actually also supported the happy log
log which we needed but they don't
support this sliding one but essentially
if you've got this RP address coming in
all we did was we added it to three
different buckets one for the month one
for the day one for an hour and then we
could get the counts out of that if you
wanted the hour count we just query that
specific bucket unfortunately the
question was are we done we have to
store everything three times with the
solution in every all the three buckets
it stores it in the computer's memory so
that was super expensive for us but we
had half a million dollars in cloud
credit which is kind of insane but
apparently it's what happens in Silicon
Valley we just got given all this money
and I'm like well we might as well use
it on this since we need to get
everything running the biggest problem
for us was that the buckets are not
accurate so if you're adding to an hour
you either get kind of the first half of
the hour the second half of the hour
we'd really wanted this kind of slotting
count and then kind of as a progress of
what we've achieved in this database
didn't have shotting the buckets weren't
accurate it was atomic which is a bit of
a interesting story for half a log-log
because you can keep
the same data and it doesn't change
anything because you counting uniques
not very cheap and not very durable
Redis gave us replication but that
doesn't matter and it wasn't fault
tolerant what we kind of migrated to
from that which is I guess where the
kind of spark storm story comes in is we
added in this thing called Kafka and
Kafka essentially it's they call
themselves a durable log of sequential
messages you send it any piece of data
and you know it's stored it it gives it
an offset so you can start streaming
from any point in time all your data is
sitting there we know it's sitting there
it's very very durable and so we just
used it as a durable log of all the
times we want to keep incrementing
counts the other interesting thing is
kefka has a very very smart client so
whatever the database isn't well I mean
it's fairly smart but you also need a
very very well-written kind code and
they do support pathan which is fairly
rare because I think the only other ones
are C++ and Java anyway and so all we
wrote to that was a timestamp aqui so
essentially this is at 225 p.m. bump
account and the initial solution was to
just do exactly the same thing move that
but then pythons pretty great with this
we could just grab this module off the
internet what we actually did as an
initial solution is literally just grab
the object use path and pickle which is
a way of turning an object into just
data and save that into race when we
looked at that data it kind of comes out
like this I don't know how many led
programming culture people in the
audience but this looks very very
similar to an oj s joke which people
often pull out part and it exactly the
same things but our basic solution to
that was just to kind of throw
compression around it because repeated
data is very easy to compress and then
you get this kind of
garbage out but it's way shorter than
the original version and we threw that
into our in memory storage again are we
done nope this thing was still in RAM we
still had a lot of cloud credit
unfortunately they expire your crowd
credit off the amount of time and we
were starting to reach that period in
time so we actually had to figure out
the proper way of doing these things but
again as the following summary shorted
accurate atomic still not cheap we did
have durable and we didn't have the
fault tolerance we actually wanted
because if that Redis server went down
our counts went down and the reddest
server went down quite a lot storing
everything in memory is not very good
for crashes because you have to kind of
recover everything and it takes a lot of
time and also Instagram also used Redis
at some point in time and they've got
hours of war stories they kind of warned
me probably shouldn't have done that but
I also didn't know what I was getting
myself into but yeah unfortunately cloud
credit doesn't last forever so we moved
to this thing called rocks DB which is
kind of a Facebook very very very
efficient database very easy to use it's
best to use it with C++ but there's also
a part in module which you can just
basically add a database to any
application very very easily very
scalable very fast very cheap so then we
started building out this kind of like
version 2 of our database where we
decided to try to do things properly so
for storage we use this rocks DB for the
protocol so we're running our own
database isn't that important from their
science view but the reddest protocol is
really simple and by using the same
thing we could kind of replace Redis
without actually having to change any
other code category used for durability
and replication the offsets thought so
this is an interesting thing with Kafka
because we were streaming this data in
if it crashed at any point we would
write how far we had gotten to the rocks
DB database so when it crashes at
comes back up it knows the last place
that got two and then it can just Rican
soom from calf got to catch up the last
like 10 15 minutes or whatever and so
that that was working really really well
essentially this would look a lot like
storm or spark I mean we pretty much
reimplemented it but we had complete
control over the database code and we
could write something very very very
simple that just did what we needed we
didn't have to run Hadoop which from the
infrastructure side is a huge pain to
run and essentially we could test this
thing on a single machine very easily
but then what we could do thanks to
modern technology is one more
infrastructure piece we could add in
which is comes from google it's how they
kind of power their data centers it's
pretty much a kool-aid for making things
work very very well basically it's just
you throw you can package this anything
you make into a container throw it on
top of Cuban eddies and it makes sure
that's running if our machines die it
moves it to another host comes back up
start streaming the data in again and
Cuban Eddie's will just make sure it's
always up always running and the other
thing it can do for us is it moves the
cloud disks around so the hard drive it
went down with usually is the same when
it comes back up with and so you only
actually lose about 10 minutes of counts
that you were running through so you
bring it back up can't capture all the
counts and you back up and running
within like 10 to 15 minutes again with
the progress summary so kefka gave us
the Chardon it's actually got this
partition thing where every database has
20 different streams and we hooked up a
single database to each one of those
streams we could shot very easily the
python thing gave us the accuracy atomic
came from the half a log now it's very
very cheap actually what's interesting
and very important when you're dealing
with Roxy
be is that it's got this thing called
prefix key compression but when we
storing hundreds of millions of counts
actually what starts charging costing a
lot of money is the name of the counter
so we have the IP person's RP address in
the name of the counter or their
websites or how many accesses have we
got from the email domain google com how
many have we gotten from the email
domain yahoo com and you'll end up
storing the word email domain in every
single counter which is very very
expensive rocks TB basically takes that
out for you and only stores the changed
butts so you can store a lot of data in
it in way way way less disk space
actually the numbers I think we got
where we moved from Redis which is in
memory very fast to rocks TV which is on
disk and we move from like 500 gigabytes
in memory to 30 gigabytes on disk so
cloud providers were happier guests as
we stopped burning as much of their
credit still durable which was thanks to
kefka still replicated and then the coup
benetti's gave us the fault tolerance
which we wanted that badly and so
essentially which I it was kind of
shocked when we finished doing this was
be both our in database which sounded
insane four or five years ago but now
using all these kind of off-the-shelf
components calf Goku benetti's rocks TB
you can kind of hook something together
process a ton of data and do it very
very cheaply without that much knowledge
of the core databases and all of that so
essentially there was only kind of 125
lines when I kind of counted it of stuff
that was specific to the sliding hop log
log and essentially the question we came
up with them was like what else could we
do with this very very simple data
streaming database architecture and we
came up with some interesting things so
the efficient list or is the way we kind
of store our labels so as people are
sending us
let's say it's a comment on a website or
payment we want to label them and keep
track of like hundreds of millions of
labels and so we did it exactly the same
way we part the labels into Kafka and
then interrupt CB and then they
queryable we built the search engine
which again was something that I didn't
think we were going to do and it seemed
to work very well essentially there you
could just trade out the kind of rocks
DB pot with a search engine database
still have the part in transforming the
code to be searched but it runs very
well and then the last very very
interesting one we did was accurate
counters so instead of using the sliding
Harper log log we traded that out for
just incrementing numbers but then we
could pipe all of our data into s3 or
some more durable store and then an hour
later we would do the exact same thing
but decrement the numbers so essentially
using that we could get very very
accurate accounts of how many times have
we seen this RP in the last day week
month but pretty much to the second and
also with like a tenth of the process
that that cost us in Redis next big
question is doing this what sucked we
had a lot of pain trying to do this
stuff you probably wouldn't experience
if you were based on sport storm in
stock spark which is I guess what people
do that I don't know if you've heard of
this new technology called docker when I
was talking about containers basically
package a program into a container and
it runs everywhere it runs the same but
it's got a lot of bugs in because it's
kind of two years old three years old
and when you're running your databases
on it those bugs really really hurt the
Cuban Eddie's discs where machine goes
down and comes up somewhere else that
sometimes gets stuck and when it's get
stuck up all our counters we're down and
also we recently got bit by another bug
with a formatted out disks so they
essentially just erased
all the data by mistake credit to Google
like we have some contacts there we
contacted them told them and they jumped
on it right away they say the bugs
solved but we haven't upgraded the
version again because we kind of staying
staying where we know it's safe I guess
and then the future work I guess we
don't have a solution for derived data
so data streams in and be savoured in
this database storm spark all of that
will let you take a further step and
reprocess that data in another way we
still we don't really have to do that
yet we're still figuring out if we
wanted to do that how could we do that
with a very very similar setup and we
looking at this thing called Kafka
streaming which takes a very very
similar approach to what we doing and
kind of gives you the same interface as
storm or spark would where you can have
your script that reads through the data
transforms it right sit back and lands
up in a database at some point in time I
guess it's probably pretty convenient
that running late because I ran through
that way too quickly but if you guys
have any questions yeah happy to take
them sure
yes sorry about that
yeah I think I think I mean on that one
of the interesting points for us was
that we had to figure out a way to do
this cheaply and a lot of like the
obvious solutions which like when you
start actually running them I mean k so
the whole red is storing everything in
memory was a bit of a joke but storm and
spark what actually has landed up
costing us a lot of money which is
something you never think about but they
charge you for sending data between
machines and that can land up being kind
of a significant portion of your costs
if you're running one of these solutions
and just kind of let it do its thing and
transfer data all around so yeah your
request so I mean many so you said mini
cube the Cuban Edison as far as I
understand so many cube as far as I
understand is just a way of running KU
benetti's on kind of a single machine
which is more kind of a development
testing environments because kind of the
think you benetti's gives you I didn't
really dive into that but essentially
you can have 100 200 machines run the
single piece of software and then say i
want this data processing pipeline to
run put it anywhere i find a spot for it
anywhere and you kind of push a button
and cuban at ease will find somewhere to
put that running it on one machine is
really nice for testing and development
but it probably doesn't bring you much
value there I don't know what you would
actually get out of it if you're running
it on so you can run black duck on a
single machine and it might be mostly
the same thing yeah so also Cuban at
ease lets you instead of just using one
docker lets you run it on like 30
different Dockers on different machines
but if you're developing on one machine
you might as well just use docker sure
yep yeah okay so I didn't dive into the
replication that much so essentially we
write all updated the kafka so all these
rocks d beatboxes do is they so I can
jump activate slice actually quite far
back there we go so that's essentially
what we write into Kafka just the
timestamp and increment and then we have
these rocks TV servers that are now
listening to that and bumping the
counters and essentially replication
instead of one server we just set up to
they don't actually have to speak to
each other at all liberal just listen to
Kafka and then you can query them for
the council's I guess so yeah I mean the
other kind of very interesting case is
when you set up the other one we could
do it from a backup of the previous one
so we had take a backup create a new
database and when we brought it up it's
probably about 40 minutes since we
started the whole process is about how
long the whole backup thing takes but
because it knows it saved the positional
zat in the CAF katrien when it comes up
and we'll start at that position and so
they both will have the same data once
it catches up the query from both
communities has this is kind of crazy
down the technology line but it has this
magic IP thing and they call class
therapy but essentially you get 11
address which links to both boxes and it
kind of chooses one at random which
makes that and if one goes down there
are only points to the one address so
that makes it very very easy to kind of
replicate like we could bring up more if
we had the need to right now we only run
two because we want to still be able to
serve counts when one goes down
yep
yes we're a start-up there are seven of
us so we don't actually have that much
team structure Carolyn works with us
she's sitting at the back but besides
heard we've got five engineers one
designer and engineers have more than
enough to work on so we kind of just sit
down and work on stuff
so we don't actually have a data
scientist yet I guess the closest we
have might be a teammate Julian who is
kind of the anti-spam guy so he will sit
there so all about all of our kind of
data we also flow into bigquery I don't
know if you've used that at all but it
kind of gives you a sequel interface to
a ridiculous amount of data and so he
will kind of search through bigquery see
if you can find anything interesting
bring that into our system try right so
we essentially write rules so we use the
way we use these counters is your rather
all saying if we've had more than five
purchases from the same IP address in
the last hour and the person making the
purchases has used more than three
unique zip codes like mark this as
suspicious so he's the person that
usually writes those rules eventually
we're going to get the customers to do
that but yes I guess he's sitting
closest to the data I'm on the
infrastructure team so that's the
closest to this stuff and making sure
the data is flowing we collecting
everything we need to and everything's
up and running and with me that to other
people
yeah I mean yeah I can I can try not
embarrass myself I guess because we
didn't we didn't put that much thought
into it we put like a bunch so they were
sometimes obvious answers we made so red
aside used before it's great we knew it
wasn't a long-term thing actually for
these counters we started with the
database cord react or ryuk I don't know
how to pronounce it which was a terrible
mistake mainly so that database does a
lot of stuff around moving data around
so it automatic magically will make sure
your data is always available and but
essentially moving data from one server
to another is expensive and it treats
that as just like a fact of life and
this solution all the data is always
sitting on one machines it's way easy to
manage way faster way cheaper the one
other very very nice thing that calf
gergely to us was that when we started
so everything's running kind of in real
time but we could back up all the counts
so we had another thing that takes
everything written to Kafka saves it for
future right now we don't save
everything anymore unfortunately but
back in the early days we could save all
our data and if we ever change database
we could just pop it through from day
one run through all the data again get
the latest counts in whatever database
we wanted to use sure
so we've recently been filling with this
what you can do so there's another tool
called succour which I think was made by
Pinterest but essentially that will
stream kefka and save it to s3 or some
kind of long-term storage we were using
that we've kind of stopped because
that's expensive and we've got a lot of
data to deal with so now we kind of
store either three or seven days worth
and Kafka pretty much just in because we
only use the real time stuff so it's
basically if something went wrong today
and I only noticed it on Monday we would
still have the data to fix it which is
why this three day and eight day is so
we can always refill a week of data yeah
so it's probably good
yeah so this is this is kind of that I
mean yeah this has a lot of depth so we
definitely more on the rule-based system
right now so most kind of answer all the
big anti-fraud companies a credit card
fraud credit card laundering all of that
they tend to use very very heavy machine
learning and the problem with machine
learning is you kind of often get this
kind of single number out so this is
eighty percent likely to be fraud and
you don't really know why especially
with often like spam the numbers kind of
vary a lot and we want to know why they
the customers want to know why we
thought this thing was bad so we would
say okay this text has racial slurs in
it and X amount of whatever we starting
to combine that with machine learning
which we're only starting to do right
now I mean we've always had a bet but we
starting to play that at much bigger
part but that's still as part of the
rule system so a sample rule would be if
this person's made more than 100
comments in the last hour and the
machine learning thinks the comments are
like a boolean or whatever then flag it
and so we are building up a machine
learning problem but I guess one of the
big company philosophies is that it's
not actually as important as everyone
else thinks it is which we think is a
good bet and guess we'll see the world
wait so the rule-based system was that
more important also machine learning is
great it's it gives you a lot of
insights that you'd probably have to
work on that kind of coming to them by
hand and when processing huge data sets
it's pretty pretty great the big problem
kind of with anti-spam anti-fraud and so
this is also coming from our contacts at
like Facebook and Google and how they
find this stuff so the game we play is
always kind of this kind of attack a
defender thing with the spammers so we
have a
grupa spam is sitting in Ukraine China
we don't really know where they are
trying to break the system and if we
have machine learning it blocks them
pretty successfully but at some point
they figure out exactly what the machine
learnings learnt about them and figure
out how to bypass that and suddenly
we've got them on board and the machine
learning might take quite a while to
pick up that and change in those so we
have kind of alarm set for when number
of comments goes up and this is kind of
suspicious at which point we'll go
humanoid look at what's coming in right
a very very simple rule that says that
if this comment contains XYZ block it
and then we actually have a way of
getting that into production within
seconds so can modify rules very very
quickly get them up and running and then
start blocking the stuff before the
machine learning kind of has caught up
the machine learning is very important
for like figuring out whether text is
bullying or where the text is this and
it's learned a whole lot of awful words
which I don't ready look here
yeah so we we basically at the moment we
take whatever we can get which our
customers tend to send us HTTP headers
kind of a bit of information about the
browser we want to get into more kind of
timing so you can kind of pick up
whether it's a home user a data center a
proxy server so someone that's accessing
through another machine you can pick up
a lot of that stuff with timing but that
requires that our customers give us that
data which is pretty that which is very
tricky to extract so we might at some
point give them a way of doing that so
far we just take the headers which you
can extract a lot of very useful
information out of yeah lots of lots of
Secrets there with just like things
spammers don't know that we have to be
careful about telling people because it
might land up back at the spanners and
then they'll break through our system
again it is it really is this like
long-term battle between us and them
cool cool questions thank you